-Our first guest directed,
co-wrote, and stars
alongside Tiffany Haddish
in the new film "Here Today."
It is available now
on digital Blu-ray and DVD.
Here is the one,
the only Billy Crystal!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
That's what I'm talking about.
Yeah!
Oh!
Look at you.
-Finally.
-Welcome back.
Billy, I'm so happy.
Thank you so much
for being here.
-Well, I wish
I actually was there, you know?
-Yeah, that's true.
-But, you know, at times there,
I'm a little afraid to fly.
So, yeah, not about the COVID.
The passengers. It's the...
[ Laughter ]
I mean, I actually called
for reservations, Jimmy,
and they asked me if I'd like
to sit in the octagon.
So, yeah, you know,
there's a three-knockdown rule
now in first class.
I don't know if
you know that, so...
I should have rimshots for this,
don't you think?
-Yeah, we can get --
Quest can do a rimshot.
[ Rimshot ]
Yeah, of course.
-Hey, last time I flew here,
the flight attendant
asked if I wanted
headphones and duct tape.
[ Rimshot ]
They stopped serving alcohol.
Now they serve Ambien.
[ Rimshot ]
-Dude, the face.
-Here's the last one.
New slogan is, "There's
something special the air."
-There you go.
-Yeah, MMA.
-That's how you do
it, ladies and gentlemen.
That's how you do it.
Write it down.
Billy, you look great.
But I heard you had
a little health scare.
Is everything all right?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That was just --
You know, I've been working out
as much as I can,
and so I did something
with my right hip.
So it was just a strange pain.
So I was worried, 'cause
I don't want to join that
"Yeah, I got a new hip" club.
So, the doctor says,
"Listen, I think the best thing
is to put you in the MRI tube,
and, you know, let's take a
good look at your soft tissue."
So I said, "Fine, but I'm 73,
so this everything is soft
at this point."
-Nothing but soft tissue.
-You've been
in an MRI tube, right?
-Yeah.
-It's awful.
I mean, I'm very claustrophobic,
which is why
I was a month premature.
And, so...
[ Laughter ]
So, I get there and I'm nervous,
and they shoot dye into the hip
and then they put me
in the hospital gown,
you know, with your ass
hangs out of the back.
It's just --
Nothing is good about this.
-Yeah, I feel like they need
to master that, yeah.
-Yes, and I'm really nervous.
So, to make a long story short,
when I was alone, I swallowed
four edibles, alright?
-Wait. What do you mean?
-Four, you know, edibles.
-Yeah, gummies.
Wow.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
'Cause the guy
at the cannabis place said --
Because there's a section
for seniors, you know?
So, he said,
"Two will make you feel good."
So I said, "Well,
I really want to feel fabulous."
So he said to have four.
-So you had four gummies.
-So, I swallow the four.
So, now I get on the thing,
and they put me into the tube.
And I have headsets on
and I'm listening to
a little Bill Evans on Pandora.
And they give you
this thing to squeeze,
so in case you get into trouble,
you just squeeze it,
and he says,
"What can I do?"
and "I'll get you
out of there," right?
So, about a half-hour in,
I got really hungry.
-Oh, my God.
You're a stoner now. Geez.
-Yeah. And, so,
I squeeze the thing.
He goes,
"Are you okay, Mr. Crystal?"
I said, "Yeah, yeah.
Is there a Taco Bell nearby?"
-By the tube, is there any --
-Yeah. No?
He said, "No."
Alright. Alright.
Okay. Alright. Alright.
Now, 40 minutes in, I squeezed
it again, and he goes,
"You're okay?"
"Yeah. Yeah.
I'm thinking if Postmates --
would they deliver?"
-Just get me a taco.
Just get me something.
Get me a burrito.
-I'm thinking gumbo
or Nutella French toast,
something like that.
-You're a stoner.
You became a stoner.
-In the tube.
And I didn't want to
open my eyes,
because I know, you know,
the roof is like right here.
-Yes.
-So I'd feel like I was, like,
you know, a mummy or something.
And, so, finally, I nodded off.
So it was like
1968 all over again,
so it's, like, very cool for me.
So, they take me out,
and I walk out of the building.
And someone says, "Um, sir,
you're still in your gown,
and your ass is hanging out."
I said, "Oh, geez."
So, I come back in,
I got dressed,
and I went to a Taco Bell
and had a nacho fry box.
-That's what I'm talking about.
See? Good.
And everything worked out?
-Yeah, I'm okay. I'm okay.
-I wanted to mention,
once again,
you're voicing Mike Wazowski.
You're back.
Because we -- You know, in
"Monsters, Inc." and the sequel.
But now it's "Monsters at Work"
on Disney+.
Any kid out there, any families
out there with kids,
you have to watch this.
You're fantastic.
-We're having a good time.
It's John Goodman
and I and Mindy Kaling,
Henry Winkler,
a young, very talented actor
named Ben Feldman.
So it's been a lot of fun.
People seem to be
really liking it.
It's a continuation of where
"Monsters, Inc." left off.
So it's not a sequel.
It's just a continuation
of the original story.
20 years ago.
This is the 20th anniversary of
"Monsters, Inc." Crazy.
-That seems --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That seems almost wrong.
That's why.
It feels like it just came out.
-Yeah.
This whole year is anniversaries
for me, though.
It's the 30th anniversary
of "City Slickers."
-Wow!
-Yeah, crazy.
And the 35th anniversary
of, really, my first role
that I really loved,
and that was "Running Scared"
with the great Gregory Hines.
-Oh, Gregory Hines. Absolutely.
I love it.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Well, I love this new film that
you have, "Here Today."
You wrote it. You directed it.
You star in it
with Tiffany Haddish,
who, by the way,
is fantastic, as well.
-Yeah, she's great.
-Why -- That's so much work.
I mean, that's...
-Well, you know, it was
something that I really loved
and I got to write it
with my dear friend
and someone you know very well,
Alan Zweibel.
-I love Alan Zweibel.
He's a legend.
-Yeah, And I saw him, actually,
on the "Letterman" show,
telling this funny story
about how he met this person
by chance
at a celebrity auction lunch.
And she purchased him for $22,
and then she ended up having
an allergic reaction
to the seafood she was eating.
And she had no insurance.
She had to get an ambulance.
And this charity lunch
cost him $3,000.
-That's so funny.
-So, I'm watching him,
Jim, and I said --
And I started typing,
"Alan, this is the beginning
of something.
I don't know what it is,
but this is how they meet.
Where do we go from there?"
And so on, so forth.
So, we just started writing,
and it ended up becoming this,
I think, really funny,
beautiful story
of these two mismatched
people who become great friends.
-Yeah, it's very funny,
but it's also --
It's got some very moving scenes
in there, too.
Can I set it up or...
-Sure.
-You're a writer
and suffering from dementia,
the first stages of dementia.
-Yes, I said, "Well, what if we
complicate it
and he's got this?"
Because the thought
of somebody funny,
whose words are his currency,
who's now going broke,
could be very dramatic
and very fascinating to play.
And can we put that into a movie
that we hope is funny,
but also entertaining and
heartbreaking at the same time?
And I'm very proud
of what we were able to do.
-Yeah, and it's tricky
to come out with a movie
during quarantine,
as well, but --
-Well, yeah, I mean,
"Mom, come on, come on.
We're going to go see
the dementia movie.
Come on! Come on!"
-Yeah, but, also --
But it's kind of good that
it's out now
and it's streaming in --
-Yeah, now people are --
I tell you,
I mean, the reaction to it now,
when people are
finally seeing it,
has been really
heartwarming and great.
And I thank everybody
who's now, you know,
getting a chance to watch it,
right, you know,
these last couple weeks.
It's great.
-Well, you did a great job.
And I love the --
There's a cameo of --
Alan Zweibel's cameo as
the cue-card guy in the show.
That made me laugh.
I just -- Yeah.
If you talk to him,
well, tell him it was great.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Billy Crystal and
Tiffany Haddish in "Here Today."
Take a look at this.
-Thank you for bidding on me
in the auction.
-Truth?
-Sure.
-I don't know
who the hell you are.
My ex bid on you.
-How come your ex didn't come?
-I caught him cheating on me.
-Oh.
-Yeah. And he said
it was because
I'm the worst lay in the world
And trust me --
he is wrong, okay?
You ought to see my moves.
It's Cirque du Soleil.
-Let's get through lunch first.
-Mm-hmm.
I'd break your back, old man.
-Thank you.
-Yeah, have you laid out, dead,
with a smile on your face.
-[ Laughs ]
-And your kids will be like,
"How did he die?
How did my dad die?"
And I would just have to look at
them in their eyes and say...
[ Chuckles ]
..."On top of me."
-That's a really lovely thought.
-[ Laughs ]
"Thank you."
That was very good.
Billy Crystal, everybody.
I love it, buddy.
Please come back.
Can't wait to see you in person.
-See you next time, Jimmy.
-"Here Today" is available
now on digital Blu-ray and DVD.